[JORDAN]: ONE OF THE THINGS YOU’VE
DONE IS TO PICK SOMEONE TO
IMITATE AND TO PULL YOURSELF TOWARDS
THEM BY THAT PROCESS OF IMITATION.
THEN WHEN YOU GOT CLOSE,
YOU PICK SOMEONE ELSE TO
IMITATE OR TO COMPARE YOURSELF WITH.
[MIKHAILA]:
COMPARE MYSELF WITH...
[JORDAN]: SURE, BUT IT’S
THE SAME THING.
THE COMPARISON IS THE SAME THING.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU COMPARE YOURSELF
TO SOMEONE, YOU START PULLING
YOURSELF TOWARDS THEM, UNLESS YOU
GET ENVIOUS AND RESENTFUL.
[MIKHAILA]: AND THAT’S WHAT
I’VE DONE THROUGHOUT MY
LIFE IS, “HEY, THAT PERSON’S
REALLY SMART AND INTERESTING.”
TRY AND ACHIEVE WHAT
THEY’RE ACHIEVING, AND THEN
ONCE YOU GET THERE, YOU PICK
SOMEBODY ABOVE YOU.
THE PROBLEM IS, THAT MEANS YOU’RE
ALWAYS KIND OF UNFULFILLED, BUT IT
ALSO MEANS YOU’RE ALWAYS GROWING.
SO THAT’S WHAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT.
[JORDAN]: THAT’S ALSO WHY JUNG
POINTED OUT, FOR EXAMPLE,
HE BELIEVED THAT THE BOOK OF
REVELATIONS HAD BEEN TACKED ONTO
THE NEW TESTAMENT, BECAUSE THE
CHRIST IN THE GOSPELS WAS PORTRAYED
TOO MUCH AS A FIGURE OF MERCY.
WHEREAS, IN REVELATIONS, CHRIST IS
PORTRAYED PRIMARILY AS A JUDGE,
AND JUNG’S EXPLANATION FOR THAT
WAS THAT EVERY IDEAL IS A JUDGE.
THE ULTIMATE IDEAL IS THE
ULTIMATE JUDGE, AND YOU
COULD SAY THE ULTIMATE
IDEAL JUDGES YOUR SOUL.
BECAUSE THAT’S VIRTUALLY THE
DEFINITION OF THE ULTIMATE IDEAL.
SO THE ULTIMATE IDEAL IS
SOMETHING TRANSCENDENT AND
DIVINE THAT JUDGES YOUR SOUL.
NOW WHAT THAT MEANS ABOUT THE
WAY THE UNIVERSE IS CONSTITUTED,
AGAIN, I HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT THE HIGHER THE IDEAL,
THE MORE SEVERE THE JUDGE.
THAT’S CLEARLY THE CASE, AND THAT
SHOULD MAKE YOU QUAKE.
WHEN YOUR CONSCIENCE ASSAULTS
YOU IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT FOR
THINGS THAT YOU’VE DONE WRONG,
IT’S BECAUSE YOU’RE QUAKING IN
YOUR BOOTS, MORALLY, BECAUSE YOU’VE
FAILED TO LIVE UP TO THIS IDEAL.
THERE’S NO ESCAPE FROM THAT.
NOT TRULY.
I DON’T BELIEVE THERE IS.